Ben de Morgan uçmaz mı Ama Morgan
morgann defa mi tak konformite akfon mi
tak
bu demli tak puding Taka metak mita
3'den Ahmet akam lahmi Tak Nah mi tak
3D abının bütün abin ama bına bence
dinah out in oct İn der nacht nah
[Müzik]
Herkese merhaba arkadaşlar Ben Almanca
öğretmenimiz Meltem kıryar Almanca dersi
Hoş geldiniz Bugün sizinle dik takı
Saydın Yani günün vakitlerini
işleyeceğiz İnşallah dersine başlamadan
önce hemen hatırlatmak istiyorum Hemen
Açıklama kısmında sizin için bütün bu
konuları ayrıntılı bir şekilde PDF
dosyası olarak iliştirdim hazırlayıp
geliştirdim yine dersten sonra sizin
için hazırladığım oyunları oynarsanız
çok güzeldi bu öğrendiklerinizi
pekiştirmiş olursunuz Öyleyse başlayalım
Evet dün vakitleri derken biliyorsunuz
burada dört tane vakit var sabah de
Morgan de ya yani diğer artık elide ya
de ya de ya değil Sadece gece dişi bir
artık ele sahip değerleri erkek artık
yerine sahip O yüzden de selam verirken
biraz bir değişikliğiniz olacak bakalım
gelen mu A gender
en büyük yazıyoruz Çünkü isimleri
hepsini büyük yazarız Almanca'da selam
verirken ne deriz önüne iyi koyarız Hood
gutın mu agaınst Günaydın mi tak tak gün
demek aslında mita orta demek mi tak ne
demek Gönül ortası Yani öğlen vakti yine
önüne koyduk kutunun bu sefer Mix yani
iyi Gün Ortası demeyeceğiz gün diyeceğiz
unuttum tak diyeceğiz ama burada bir şey
da hatırlatmak istiyorum şu iki vakit
arasında Yani öğleden öncesi var ve
sonrası var o yüzden de bu
kelimelerinizin ismini diğer soğan mi
tak Yani öğleden önce de yan Ahmet Ak
öğleden sonra Evet bunlar da böyle
kelimelerin ama selam verirken bütün
Vita good for me tak temiz Putin takip
ederiz Evet
3D A ben twdown akşam demek yine
önlerine koyduk kurt kutunun abi iyi
akşamlar Evet gecemiz biraz farklı
artikeli farklı olduğu için buradaki
çekim ise de şu an biz okunuyor şu anda
girmeyeceğiz hiç gerek yok ya edeceğiz
din naht gece iyi geceler Itır naht
gutrot İyi geceler iyi uykular anlamında
bunu da söyleriz Evet şimdi bu
kelimeleri Biz vakitleri cümle içinde
nasıl kullanacağız önüne ve arkasına mı
Ne koyacağız bakalım Evet şimdi sabah
ben sabah okula gidiyorum derken sabah
okula gidiyorum Sabah vakti derken önüne
ammo indireceğiz ama Morgan öğlen dersek
ne edeceğiz Amme Tak böyle den önce
derse Come for me tak işte ya Ahmet Aksu
Şule ya da eşi
bu çıkığa Morgan Ben sabahları kahvaltı
yaparım Sabahları sabah vakti önünü an
koyacağız ama gınam mi tak ama bınt
akşam vakti ama burada yine gramerden
dolayı Ne diyeceğiz India DC izinden aht
bunu ne ki farklı Evet bu şekilde de biz
bunu vakitte yaptığımızı bileceğiz Evet
peki
Bu baş harfi büyük demiştik ama şimdi
küçüklük onu unutmayın küçüldü Ve sonuna
da Ne koyduk s koyduk o zaman ne oluyor
yani sürekli ben bu işi bu zamanda
yaparım de Mütemadiyen Ben öyle yaparım
ne demek mortgage su Şuraya da moans
kaybediş Fuat Ben sabahları hep yani
düzenli olarak spor yaparım mavi skyfish
Fuat Morgan su Play'e cfus bal gibi
mesela burada da aynı şekilde falan
Mithat mi taksın Ahmet Aksöz öğleden
Sonraları hep ben bu şu işi yaparım gibi
ablanız Akşamları abının sese iş Pizza
Ben akşamları Pizza yarım gibi binax
geceleri Roman okurum Nah Neyse değişik
olmanı nasılsınız iş ya da da ne
istiyorsanız onu söyleyebilirsiniz Bu da
geceleri demek yine hatırlatayım
Bu baş harfini küçük yazıyorsunuz Evet
bunlar da basit kurallarımız Şimdi bir
de bu kuralları yine hangi güne
uygulayabiliriz haftanın gönlüne de
uygularız O yüzden size sadece bir örnek
yazdım haftanın günlerini biliyorsunuz
diğer montak pazartesi günü pazartesi
günleri pazartesi gününde okula giderim
ilişki yağı amont Aksu Şule yine ipimizi
unutmuyoruz Çünkü bunun artık evde de
olduğu için aynı şekilde kullanacağız
bunu da Evet her pazartesi günü ben
futbol oynarım mont aks küçük yazdım
sonra s koydum monta Xperia iş footbar
pazartesi günleri düzenli olarak ne
yapalım futbol oynarım demiş olduk bunu
da unutuyorsunuz küçük yazılıyor vs
konuluyor Evet bu vakitlerde bu ekleri
kullandık yani a
ne aldın de olduğu için burada sadece
indiren rahat kullandık hepsine s
harfini ekledik ve küçükle başladık O
zaman da bulaşık sürekli yaptığımız
anlatmış olduk Peki saatleri Nasıl
söyleriz Ben pazartesi günü saat 9'da
falan falan işte şunu yaparım diyeceğim
zaman ne diyeceğiz saatten bahsederken
bakın novasaat demekti o oğlum yani
uauauaua o öyle kodlayın kendinizi Onlar
ona coffence iş Bir önceki derslerimizde
saatlerimiz var biliyorsunuz saatlerinde
İnşallah öğrenirsiniz öğrenmişsiniz dir
un kullanacağız unu ya da un
kullanacağız Evet bunlar bizim
kullanmamız gereken önekler ya da ya
arkaya taktığımız harfler tamam mı
Bunları unutmuyorsun Şimdi bunlar da
devam edelim
mi Evet şimdi Ne yapalım birşeyleri
birbirine karıştıralım Ne yapalım Mesela
diyelim ki pazartesi Akşamları ben kursa
giderim İngilizce kursuna gidelim
diyelim ki pazartesi günü artı akşam ne
yapacağız o zaman yine aynı şekilde
ikincisi koyacağız o saatte ben oraya
giderim derken o vakitte montajı yani
haftanın günü başa koyacağız Biz
Türkçede öyle yaparız pazartesi akşam
atarız akşam Pazartesi demeyiz aynı
şekilde monta kabın önünde ikincisi
koyduk ne olduğu iş ki ıııı iş Biz ruhu
ya da ilişki yağı Amon tak abin tsun
English kovası Yani ben Pazartesi akşamı
İngilizce kursuna gittim ya da ben bunu
hep yaparım her hafta kursa giderim
küçük yazdım çünkü sonra s harfini
koyduğum için ve sürekli ben bunu
yaptığım için mutlaka Bence K2 Turkuaz
var Yani bu da bu şekilde birleşiyor o
kadar Evet aynı bu örnekte benzeri zaten
fay tak Cuma günü ne zaman hangi vakit
sabah yani Cuma sabahı AMF Ay Takma Gun
ya da küçük yazdım Çünkü ben başı
sürekli yapıyorum Ve sonra s harfini
koydum far takma aldığınız şubemi iş ben
Cuma Sabahları üzerim Evet bunlar da bu
da karıştıra bileceğimiz kullanışlı
bilgiler Evet şimdi cümlelerinizi
kuralım bakalım Evet şimdi cümlelerimiz
E geçelim bakalım cümleleri geçmeden
önce size çok önemli ipuçlarını söylemem
lazım Bunlar nedir bunlar bizim şiirimiz
yani yüklememiz ile ilgili sorun Burada
gördüğünüz gibi bakın siirlerimiz
görüyor musunuz hepsi nerede
bu orta diyemeyiz Çünkü mesela bunda
birçok dört tane unsurlar orta neye göre
Bunların hepsi iki pozisyonda bunun
pozisyonu hiçbir zaman değiştireceğiz
Bir de bir de mesela ben buraya nesne
dediğimiz yani Öf şiirden etkilenen
olarak bunları da en sona yazdım bunları
başa da yazabilirsiniz ortaya da
yazabilirsiniz ama tavsiye edilen
bunların da sonda olması daha iyi Hani
Eğer illaki sinemaya bulacaksınız Onbaşı
yazabilirsiniz şimdi o kadar ayrıntıya
girmeyelim Bir de yeni kelimelerimiz var
Onlara bakalım Mesela ins Kino Bu bir
kalıp bunu bu şekilde ezberliyoruz
sinemaya demek ins Kino ya da başka
nereye gideriz hergün gittiğimiz İnci
Şule okula indi Şule bunları kalıp
olarak gramer olarak öğrenirsek işin
içinden çıkamayız ne havuzu eve ein
bu video indi şu Lena havuzu bunları
kalıbıyla ezberleyin lütfen Evet devam
edelim şimdi dikkat etmemiz gereken
yükleme mizin dilimizin ikinci
pozisyonda olması Diğer öğeleri böyle
puzzle gibi yer değiştirebilirim bakalım
şimdi İş ben yani özneyi Boşa Koydum iki
pozisyon iş şubemi Amon tak Ben
pazartesi günü İkimiz de koydum
Pazartesi günü gününde yaptığım için
işlemi Amon tak Ben pazartesi günü
yüzerim başka nasıl ifade edebiliriz
hiçbir şekilde devrik cümle olmadan bunu
başa alırız Amon tak tak şubemi şüphem
ayı neye göre çektim Tabii ki özneye
göre çektim şimdi bir kural daha var
bakın özne ve yüklem bunlar anne çocuk
gibidir Bunları asla BİM'den
ayırmalısınız yoksa cümle yanlış olur
Bakın
o yapışık bunu yapışık burada yapışık mı
yapışık yani sorun yok ama un Tak şu ve
ma iş Ben pazartesi günü üzerim Belki
bunu bir de saat koyalım Ben pazartesi
günü 8'de üzerimde sevdim Ne diyecektim
shimmy shimmy Mahmut Atakum'un
koyuyorduk önüne ona Ah to a Ben
pazartesi günü saat 8'de yüzerim aynı
şekilde a monte kum ahua şube ma iş
cümlemiz mükemmel oldu Evet devam edelim
başka bir örneğe geçelim dusen Games
Games çektim neye göre çektim doğuya
göre çektim duke's ta Benz bakın
aldığımız küçük yazdım ve sonrası ya
koydum yani her akşam ben bu işi zaten
yaparım Mütemadiyen yaparım alışkanlık
olmuş Dogs tabın sen gidiyorsun akşam
ve ins Kino ins Kino sinemaya sen
akşamları sinemaya gidersin bunu
değiştirelim mi değiştirelim değilim ki
sen akşamları bu kaçta gidelim gece ona
gidelim Dogs tabın somun
Ben senin o a
bu Insignia Tamam şimdi öğelerin yerini
değiştirelim ins Kino ya dokunmuyorum
onu yine sonunda bırakacağım ama bunları
değiştireceğim Evet ne değiştirebilirim
aldığınız başa koydum ama biz fiili Hiç
ellemedim o iki pozisyonda kaldı abın
sgis Doğu yer değiştirdi aldığınız gesto
ins Kino bitti Bakalım doğru bir cümlemi
yüklememiz ikide mi Evet Peki yanında
özne var mı savunmaya da solunda Evet
özledi hemen yanında o zaman cümlemiz
doğru daha güzel cümle olması için de
sinemaya Nereye koydum en sona koydum
nesne en sona koyuyorum Evet devam
edelim Evet Ali Ali de devam edelim Ali
kontum ah to a Ali geliyorum Ah dua
saati koyduğumuz bu sefer mesela akşam
Bu belirtmedim sadece sağlıklı koydum o
Akdoğan e havuza eve eve eve en son
yazdım Ali geliyor eve kaçta saat 8'de
geliştirelim bunu umah to a komik
idealine havuzu Buraya mesela sabah
diyebilirim ya da akşam diyelim Ama bınt
umah Tuana havuzu Maho Ama bunda olur
ama bu şekilde daha iyi Evet bunlarda
bizim cümlelerimiz şimdi cümlelerimi
öğrendiğimize göre ne yapacağız şimdi
artık bunların sorusunu sormamız lazım
yani ne soracağız Sen hangi gün
yüzüyorsun yani zaman sorumuza geçelim
Evet şimdi ne zaman sorusuna başlayalım
ne zaman ne demek Man Demek ki neyle
yazıyorsunuz vanvan kelimesi Yani bu da
bu ile başlayan ve harfi ile başlayan
bütün soru kelimeleri hepsinde bu
kelimemiz en başa koyacağız şimdi
formülü müze bakalım en başa bana yazdık
One ne zaman sonrakine YouTube Evimiz
nerede ikinci pozisyonda da Evet sonra
özneyle yüklem ayrılmayacağına görene
olması lazım başa koyacağımız a göre
yükleme onu da üçüncü pozisyonu koymak
zorundayız formu hep aynı başa One
yüklem fiil yani yapılan iş ve hemen
arkasından kim yapıyor işi bunların
üçünü sıraladık mı Artık çok büyük bir
yanlış yapamayız Evet bakalım One fiil
özne ve sonra varsa nesne bazen de
yoktur mesela ilk cümlemize yok Bakalım
eşi ve takom Ah dua olurdu olmaz
da bakalım şimdi bunun cevabını sorusunu
soralım Van şube miniş Ben ne zaman
yüzüyorum biraz garip bir soru oldu
yok baban şüphem su da diyebiliriz buna
sen ne zaman yüzüyorsun vs burada nesne
yok Ne yaptın başa bana koydum şiirimi
koydum ve hemen arkasından özneyi koydum
çünkü sildi özleyeyim Mecburum
birleştirmeye Evet şimdi nesneli bir
soru soralım One ne zaman stilimizi ki
de Giz gidiyor gidiyor sundu Sen hemen
üçte Ne kaldı geriye Neslimiz kaldı şu
zamanı kaldırdık onu sorduğumuz için Var
mı isteğin skinos en sinemaya ne zaman
gidiyorsun Evet devam edelim Ali ne
yapmıştı saat 8'de eve gelmişti Ali ne
zaman eve geliyor Van'ı başa koydum puan
fiili ikiye koydum ben komut Ali Ali
özne üçe koydum Bitti Ne kaldı Gel Ne
kaldı daha fazla bari komut Alina havuzu
Ali eve ne zaman gelir Evet bu formunuza
bu kadar basit saat bilgisini
ya hani One diye sorabilirsiniz ya da o
mi Filo da sorabilirsiniz ama One ne
zaman aynı Türkçe'deki gibi ne zaman
anlamını taşıyor Evet bugünkü konumuz bu
kadar tekrar hatırlatayım alıştırmaları
mutlaka yapın Eminim çok faydasını
göreceksiniz Bir sonraki derste görüşmek
üzere hoşçakalın ha